ladies and gentlemen mr. Tom Cruise
good evening gentlemen and ladies don't
start your engines because this winter
is already in and it's my pleasure to
present his trophy for me the pride of
being part of these evenings comes from
a moment like this the Board of
Governors has voted the Jean Hersholt
award to an actor director who uses his
considerable fame more than considerable
charm and bottomless compassion to make
this world a safer happier place for
some of us in our kids the Academy's
Oscar is a measure of a movie makers art
the Hersholt is a measure of his heart
no star has ever sought either less or
deserve both more than Paul Newman
consider some of these statistics at
Paul's extraordinary generosity over 80
million dollars from his own line of
Newman's Own food products a company
that allocates 100 percent of its
profits to charity the money is
channelled into compassionate and
educational activities from camps for
children battling cancer to programs
preventing and healing the ravages drug
abuse to New Directions in education to
providing new opportunities for the
handicapped of famous people players
Paul Newman gives more the money he
gives himself
I am very very proud to present the Jean
Hersholt award to my treasured friend my
respected colleague admired mentor and
fellow racecar driver
ladies and gentlemen our own Paul Newman
thank you I you know I I think we're
reminded too frequently about the things
that don't work in this country and not
frequently enough about the things that
do and my estimation the United States
is the most generous country on the face
of the planet
and and in the nation there are a group
of communities in one of those
communities is the communities of
artists and entertainers and I think
they are the most generous community in
the United States and not just in terms
of money but in terms of inspiration and
effort and time and commitment and risk
so to be singled out like this out of
that community I must say is an honor
and he thank you Anthony Hopkins and
Geena Davis next plus a performance by
Bruce Springsteen